SPEAKER: Looking for a database
service that will free you up
from thankless administrative
and management tasks?
Google Cloud Spanner,
the horizontally scalable
relational database
service, offers industry
leading five nines availability.
Meaning the database
behind your app
has 10 times less downtime
than other databases.
Plus, it's simple to deploy.
And scaling up is as
easy as two clicks.
Automation of complex tasks
like partitioning data
across a database and global
synchronous replication
are built in as standard--
not as expensive add-ons.
This frees up your IT resource
to focus on what's important--
your application.
With a simplified
pricing model that
removes unnecessary
complexity and Google-grade
security included by
default, Cloud Spanner
has all the ingredients
required to simplify
database management.
With Google Cloud Spanner,
there's less administration.
Meaning you can
focus on innovation.